the left has a war on the whole idea of
gender it's a war on men but it's also
war on women and look no further than
their campaign to get biological men
into women's sports I mean this is
insane we couldn't even have imagined
this conversation three or four years
ago but the idea that it is now like an
Article of Faith with them that a
biological man must be able to play in
women's sports and use the locker room
with the girls is insane
thank you
you've been leading on the tech stuff
sort of outside of this but this is
obviously very connected to the tech
side of it I mean I'll watch my niece
flip through Tick Tock and you know you
just suddenly out of nowhere literally
you know she's suddenly It's My Little
Pony and then it's and then it's some
weird gender thing and then five more
videos and something else what do we do
about that and uh you know I know you've
been one of the guys trying to figure
out okay do we do we break them up when
are we supposed to use government power
here
well I I just say again as a dad I would
I want to raise my kids my wife and I we
want to raise our kids I don't want big
Tech raising them for me I don't want
some algorithm raising it for me period
so I'm against Tech being able to track
our kids all over the Internet collect
all their personal information build
dossiers on them I think we should just
prohibit that just straight up like you
cannot Target children under a certain
age you cannot build dossiers on them
and I think we ought to give every
parent in America the right to get their
kids information back from all these
social media platforms you got to be
able as a father to go on and say okay
my 10 year old kid and my kids are not
on social media but you know I know the
day is coming I'm trying to delay it but
as a parent I want the right to go on
and say I want from Facebook everything
you've collected on my kid I want it all
back you delete it give it to me delete
it every parent
ought to have that basic right you
mentioned breaking them up I am a big
competition guy so my view is is that
Facebook Google their monopolies I mean
they really are they've tried to kill
comp petition all the time we ought to
break them up and let there be more
competition we ought to we ought to
allow others to get in there to compete
and to have real privacy protections but
bottom line is we've got to give power
to parents got to give them power to
protect their kids to get their kids
information don't allow big Tech to
raise kids yeah did you focus at all on
the on the female side of this I know
that obviously the book is about young
males there's a whole other set of
issues happening with young females many
of them seem to be transitioning more
than males although it's happening both
directions but I assume you think some
of the issues are somewhat constant oh
absolutely and particularly with tech I
mean listen I think the left the left
has a war on the whole idea of gender
it's a war on men but it's also war on
women and look no further than their
campaign to get biological men into
women's sports I mean this is insane we
couldn't even have imagined this
conversation three or four years ago but
the idea that it is now like an Article
of Faith with them that a biological man
must be able to play in women's sports
and use the locker room with the girls
is insane so yeah I think what you're
seeing from the left again from the
Marxist left really is a campaign
against gender it's against Womanhood
it's against manhood there are a lot of
similarities there in how they're trying
to destroy these things that are
permanent these things that are constant
and we've got to stand up for them so
conservatives got to stand up and say no
you know what you don't get to be a
Woman by just wanting to be a woman
there is such a thing as biological
Womanhood and it's awesome and should be
protected and girls playing sports
should be protected and Men on your side
of the aisle your side of the equation
we need you to be good strong men and we
need you to stand up and be providers
and be responsible so we've got to do
both and I think the left is really
attacking both men and women and you you
can see it you can see it in the in the
huge number of kids now who are totally
confused about their gender and say that
they they want to transition they don't
even know what that means and it's being
promoted by leftist ideology and the
alliance with big Tech yeah you know one
of Jordan Peterson's lines on this is
even if you were to take the the kid who
is the point zero zero zero one percent
that has gender uh dysmorphia it doesn't
mean after all the hormones and
surgeries that they're going to be
happier they most likely won't be
actually and that's in the case of when
it genuinely is real which obviously
there's a social contagion element to
this yeah totally and if you look at
those numbers it's really striking if
you look at the breakdown and gender
dysphoria in those cases clinically
diagnosed from say 10 years ago 15 years
ago versus today it is impossible to
argue I think that this isn't a social
contagion you look at it those years ago
and the huge explosion huge win right
around the time the smartphone and
social media really take off and that
every teenager in America has one boom
right then we see huge numbers and it is
the gender dysphoria issue is
concentrated largely in in young girls
in in teenage and preteen girls and
we've seen just off the charts numbers
there and for the left to say stuff like
oh we we have to we have to be for this
we've got to promote gender transition
gender surgery hormone treatment I mean
I think this is crazy when parents don't
know if the parents haven't consented
looking at what that what is really
driving this the social contagion again
the left is so out of touch with reality
and is so contrary to what parents want
are you guys in Missouri doing anything
like what we've done here in Florida
with the parental rights and education
Bill are they are they allowed to do
this in schools without you knowing as
the parent
you know the the Missouri legislature I
think has done some really good work
both on parental rights when it comes to
schools and then also just on this
gender treatment issue saying that
listen you know parents you can't push
this gender trans ideology on kids
Behind parents back you can't do this
without parental consent you can't do
this without getting the miners full
consent so just in this last legislative
session I think our legislators have
done some really important stuff and
it's going to take you mentioned the
states it's going to take the states
stepping up here and creating walls
around the family and saying we're going
to protect parents and we're going to
protect kids and we're going to empower
parents because if we don't do that at
the state level
these the bureaucrats will just run
roughshod over families over kids and
they will push their ideology until they
get what they want yeah you know it's
funny I can't really get Democrats to
come on this show anymore and I'm not
noted as the hardest interviewer and I
would treat them with respect but they
they simply don't want to do it but when
you talk or I'm guessing you know they
don't talk to you that often probably
either but if you're in the Senate
you're wandering around the building the
office is over there and you happen to
see somebody Chuck Schumer somebody that
I'm not talking one of the real real
radicals like someone that 20 years ago
might have been thought of as somewhat
sane did they buy this didn't they all
just vote against a bill that was going
to protect girls in sports every single
Democrat yeah they did over on the house
side and I'm sure they'd vote against
the Senate yeah I don't know what what
their real beliefs are and I you know I
won't pretend to speak for them but I
just think that the radical left
the Marxist left has so captured the
Democrat Party that they live in fear I
think they just live that's why they
won't say the word woman you know they
say people with birthing capacity they
can't even when I say when I say they I
mean Senators Democrat Senators won't
say woman anymore I mean it's just it is
insane insane and I think it is fear of
the radical left who are so powerful now
in their party yeah where do you think
uh education comes into this in terms of
what what a man should do with his life
you know we sort of have this idea that
everybody had to go to the four-year
school we now know that they were
basically brainwashing everybody but
that there were a lot of other jobs and
things that you can do in your life that
are valuable without following that that
path
oh yeah I believe that 100 listen 70
plus percent of American men do not have
a four-year college degree they
shouldn't have to get one in order to
get a good paying job in this country
and be able to provide for a family
that's my bottom line so I'm not for
this shove kids and shove young men in
particular towards four-year degrees
make them take on tremendous amounts of
debt allow them to be brainwashed by the
the university establishment who are
some of the worst actors in America you
talk about what they've done to this
country while taking our money by the
way I mean just taking gobbling up
taxpayer money and yet indoctrinating
our kids so no I'm not for forcing
people to go down that route I think
that they ought to men ought to be able
to learn a trade they want to do that
get an associate's degree not go to
college and they ought to be able to get
a good paying job and I just come back
to the fact that our policy makers have
sent almost 4 million blue-collar jobs
to China in the last 20 years those jobs
are jobs that used to be able to support
a family overwhelmingly held by men we
need good blue-collar work in this
country and if we don't get it we're not
going to have a country
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell